- Welcome back.
We've got the one and only,
Carol Burnett with us
on her 90th birthday.
(audience applauds)
- You can see her tribute,
"Carol Burnett: 90 Years
of Laughter and Love"
tonight on NBC.
Right now, we're actually gonna go
through Carol's scrapbooks.
So, let's flip to some other memories
from "The Carol Burnett Show",
the movie parody she did.
So, one of Carol's favorite
parodies was called,
Lovely Story, based on the famous film
"Love Story" from 1970.
So, let's see a little of that.
- What is it, doc?
- I'm afraid she only
has five minutes to live.
(audience laughs)
(dramatic music)
- Oh, no.
Oh, no.
(actor cries)
Five minutes to live.
She's so young, so pretty.
It's not fair.
Oh, doctor, what can I do?
- Well, first of all, don't overact.
(audience laughs)
- I know, I know.
I'll act as though nothing had happened.
(actor sniffs)
Hey, funny face.
(audience laughs)
Guess what?
- What?
- The doctor says you're
gonna be all right.
There's nothing wrong.
- Oh.
- How about that?
Hey, how'd you like something to eat?
- I'd love a four minute egg.
(audience laughs)
- It holds up.
(audience applauds)
It's like, it holds up, oh, my God.
What do you remember about that?
- That's, that's one of
the funniest lines ever.
- Oh my gosh, it's hilarious.
- I'd love a four minute...
I, oh, that was great.
And I got a phone call from Ali MacGraw,
who was...
- In the original.
- In the movie.
- Yeah.
- She loved it.
- She absolutely, she said,
it was a, it was hysterical.
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
- Ryan O'Neal wasn't thrilled.
- Yeah.
- No, he didn't like...
(Kelly laughs)
- Right, because the overacting.
- Probably.
- Once "The Carol Burnett Show" ended,
Carol moved on to other
TV and film projects
including playing Miss
Hannigan in the movie "Annie".
(audience applauds)
So, Miss Hannigan was pretty scary.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I feel like, how did kids react?
Like did they, did they in real life
think maybe you were mean?
(Carol laughs)
- Sometimes, it depends
on how old they are.
I might be in a restaurant and,
because now they're watching it, you know,
they, they bought the...
- Yeah.
- DVD and everything.
- So, it's a lot of, lot of little kids
are still watching it.
And it depends on how old they are,
if they're really young,
they kind of slink back a
little bit if they recognize me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then, I always say,
"I was just pretending".
(Kelly laughs)
- Yes, really not her.
- [Carol] Not her at all.
- I'm a really good actor.
(Kelly laughs)
- But then, when they get older,
they, they're, like, kind of
excited to meet Miss Hannigan.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I said, "I really
do love little girls".
And I'm not, you know.
- It's such an amazing
thing right, though?
To be a part of people's
childhood like that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, it's just, it's,
there's very few films
like "Annie", "Sound of Music", like...
- [Carol] Right.
- Just certain things you watch
when you're a kid growing up
and then, you meet, that's, it's a,
not everybody has that weight
in pop culture, I don't think.
- [Carol] Well, what was
wonderful too, in filming it
the little orphans that, you know,
the little kids who played
the orphans were all adorable.
They were, yeah.
There wasn't one brat in the pack.
- [Kelly] Really?
(audience laughs)
- [Carol] No.
And of course, Aileen
Quinn, who played Annie.
- Yeah.
- You know, she's a grown up lady now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she's on the special that we did.
- I know.
- Yeah.
- Coming out and singing,
that was incredible.
- [Carol] Yeah.
- Well, moving on to the mid 1980s,
we've gotta keep things
moving, it's a lot of years.
So, and the 1990s, Carol had serious roles
in TV, movies like "Friendly Fire",
dramatic roles in shows like "Magnum P.I."
and acted in sitcoms like "Mad About You".
I loved all of those.
So, you've had so many different roles.
So, one of your most
dramatic was "Friendly Fire".
So, how did that come about?
Did you wanna go dramatic?
Was this something that you wanted to do?
- Well, I didn't shy away from it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But nobody really ever
thought of me to do that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I remember when I got the script,
I kept looking, did they
send, it did have my name on,
on the envelope, you know?
And what happened was that
the director was British,
so he didn't know my work
that much on the show and,
but he saw me do the last show
when I said goodnight and
goodbye for the 11 years,
where I'm sitting on the
bucket as a chairwoman
and I'm talking about and,
and I did get a little
teary-eyed and stuff like that.
And he said, "I think I want
her to read the script".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That was that.
- I'm telling you, the death...
- Out of the blue.
- Yeah.
- That's just from that one
moment, isn't that crazy?
- [Carol] Yeah.
- What's even crazier
is that you were like,
he wasn't familiar with your work.
That's, that's even crazier to me.
I'm like, "Well, I've just
been here for a minute".
A, a scrapbook wouldn't be a scrapbook
if we didn't have a page dedicated
to all the awards that you have won.
So, in addition to many
entertainment awards,
(audience applauds)
Carol is a Kennedy Center
Honors Presidential Medal
of Freedom and the Mark Twain Prize
for American Humor recipient.
So, of all the honors you've been given,
was there one that surprised you the most?
That you were like, "Wow".
- Well, the one that
surprised me was the, uh,
surprise, was the recent one,
The Golden Globe for
Television Performance.
But...
- Yeah.
- They made it a, like they had
the Cecil B. Demille Award for movies,
they made it the Carol
Burnett Award for television.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Incredible.
- But my, but my, I guess
my favorite award...
- I cry a lot on this show.
(Kelly laughs)
- Thank you, my favorite...
- They've always got a stock.
- My favorite one, was the
very first one I ever got.
And that was at UCLA in 1952.
- Yeah.
- I was the most outstanding newcomer
in the theater arts department.
- Oh, my God.
(audience applauds)
- So, I still have that, yeah.
- That's so funny, because still the,
the thing that I thought, I mean,
I've won awards, but like, I
remember even in my yearbook,
like in high school, they've got,
I got like most talented and
I was like, "Wait, what?"
Like, there were so many talented people
that I went to school with and I was like,
I, it's so funny what sticks out to you.
Like, you win Grammys, you win things,
but it's like those...
- First ones.
- Because I think those
first ones kind of,
really do push you to keep going and like,
give you confidence.
- Right, absolutely.
- Yeah, we talked about
how hard it was for a woman
in entertainment during the
earlier parts of Carol's career.
So, so many of the biggest women
in comedy say you paved the way for them,
because that's true.
Like Maya Rudolph, Amy
Poehler, Jane Lynch,
all those women, hilarious
and I love to death.
So, what does that mean to
you when people say that?
That you've kind of pioneered the way and,
and opened up opportunity?
- You know, what I say is,
if I had never been born,
they would be doing what they're doing.
- I, I mean, agreed in a certain sense.
- [Carol] Talent will out.
- But not everybody can,
not everybody, you know,
is told, "Oh, this is, this is, you know,
the gals do something else,
this is what the men do".
Not every, some people, you know,
get that hurdle and then
they, it becomes a stop sign.
- [Carol] Yeah.
- And some people look at it as a hurdle
and they, they're like,
"Okay, I'm gonna persevere".
So, not everybody does that.
What, why do you think you were that kid?
That was like, "No, I'm
gonna plow through it".
I feel like I'm that kid that I'm like,
you tell me you can't and it
makes me wanna show you I can.
- I, I don't know.
I just, I, I was secure
in what I was doing.
But then also, sometimes,
a lot of times, I get a fan
mail or whatever that says,
how, how do you deal with rejection?
- Yeah.
- You know, and I remember I was up for,
not a big thing,
in New York, one of the early auditions
and it narrowed down
to another girl and me.
- Hmm-mm.
- And I thought I had
it, I thought I had it.
And I said, "Oh, this is it".
Well I didn't, she got it.
But you know what saved
me from being depressed?
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- I thought, "Well wait
a minute, it's her turn".
- Oh, wow.
- It's not my turn.
- What a beautiful way to look at it.
- My turn will happen.
- Yeah.
- But right now, it's her turn and that,
it, I give people that advice.
I said, you know what...
- [Kelly] That's great advice.
- It just might not be your turn yet.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But if you have the fire in your belly
and you really wanna do it
and you study hard and everything...
- [Kelly] Keep going.
- Your turn will come.
- Yeah, that's great advice.
- Yes.
(audience applauds)
- Well, let's turn to more
recent projects right now.
You've got a Critics' Choice
Award nomination this year
for "Better Call Saul".
And you're working on a
new series as well, right?
- Yes.
- What's the new series again?
- It's called "Palm Royale".
- [Kelly] "Palm Royale".
- And it's stars Kristen Wiig,
Allison Janney, Laura Dern.
- What a cast.
- Ricky Martin.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Oh, so many wonderful people.
And it takes place in
Palm Beach in the 1970s.
And it's all about these snooty,
Palm Beach Florida Society
and I'm the matriarch.
- Oh, my God, what a fun role.
- It is, it is fun.
- Yeah.
- Do you like playing those kind of roles,
where you kind of get...
- Sure.
- Exactly.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah, because it's not
your person in real life,
but you do it real well on TV.
- Thank you.
- It's amazing.
(Kelly chuckles)
Well, NBC is celebrating your career
with a huge tribute tonight.
So, can you describe
the show for everybody
that hasn't seen it?
- Well, it's...
- Everyone came.
- Oh, it, it's, I was gobsmacked
by all the people who showed up and came.
- Yeah.
- It's like an old time variety show.
We have a 19 piece orchestra.
- Wow.
- 19 piece orchestra, live entertainment,
singing with Bernadette Peters,
Billy Porter, Jane Lynch, Katy Perry.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Appearances by Cher and
all of the ladies in...
- [Kelly] Gosh.
- In "Palm Royale", Bob Odenkirk
from "Better Call Saul".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean, it was just
absolutely incredible.
And of course, my chum, Julie Andrews.
- [Kelly] Julie was there, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Sitting next to me.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, Lily Thomas, I
mean on and on and on.
And just a, a...
- What a perfect way to celebrate.
- [Carol] Yeah.
- You, because that's how
you like to celebrate life.
- [Carol] Absolutely, thank you.
- [Kelly] You know, that's
how you've touched us all,
it's such a perfect way.
We have a clip, so here's "Carol Burnett:
90 Years of Laughter and Love".
- When I was outside,
people were asking me
questions, questions,
questions about you.
And I said, "Oh, she's
kind and she's funny
and she teaches you so much.
And she's the kind of woman, kind of star
that if you meet her, you're
never gonna be disappointed".
I can always think of, just,
her being so kind and helping me,
because I wasn't really sure
what I was doing, you know.
Because I'd had Sonny as a partner
and when I went on my own,
I was really frightened
and you helped me and you know, you did.
And I don't know, I just love her
and I wanted to be just like her.
And I'm not just like you,
but I'm my own version of you.